[Musique]
c'est à deux pas du parc monceau que
madame des tifs il donne ses
consultations dans la somme et ben ça
n'est pas elle mais il est fort probable
que la traversée du jardin lui fournisse
un terrain idéal d'inspiration ou des
renseignements intéressants
chaque couple évoquant qui est un
exemple à suivre
qui un exemple à éviter madame betty
fine et en elle-même un vivant exemple
de charme féminin
or elle a bien voulu pour au delà de
l'écran me réserver un entretien juste
avant son cours collectifs aujourd'hui
la leçon a pour objet la morphologie
c'est à dire l'étude de la structure des
visages et les élèves sont invités à
prendre des notes afin de mieux fixer
dans leur mémoire
les principaux rudiments de cette
science qui va me permettre dès le
premier abord de reconnaître l'essentiel
du caractère de celui ou de celle qu'ils
devront charmer c'est au moyen de petits
sketches joués par les élèves de madame
betty film illustre ces exemples avant
tout de la bonne humeur et du sourire
mais ce sont les consultations
particulières uniquement d'ailleurs
réservé aux femmes qui sont les plus
efficaces et à cet effet elle a bien
voulu me préciser quelques cas d'espèce
ata très fréquents la timide affolé à
l'idée de traverser un salon
et si glissant comme une voleuse la même
ayant mal digéré la leçon est que pour
se guérir de sa timidité en fait
visiblement trop en l'amour ce n'est pas
parce que vous êtes confortablement
installé dans une romance de tout repos
qui ne faut plus prêter attention qu'aux
autres hommes car séduire c'est bien
mais retenir c'est mieux une grande
vérité donné confiance
encourager si votre mari fait montre
d'une bonne volonté attendrissante en
s'astreignant à des efforts de culture
physique méritoire il sera toujours
heureux de croire quand vous le lui
dirai qu'il retrouve doucement sa ligne
de jeune non mais oui
de même ne lui ménage est pas votre
admiration s'il veut qu'on le prenne
pour un intellectuel au téléphone le
charme ne consiste même si vous êtes
très occupé à allauch d'écouter votre
interlocuteur avec bienveillance
de ne pas trop parler la bouche pleine
[Musique]
de prendre moins de confiture et
d'autres plus sucré mais oui mon chéri
pour restaurant pour un tout petit
incident ne devenez pas la dame qui
prend la situation en main fait acte
d'autorité prétend que ceci est trop
chaud ou trop froid mobilise de
personnel en appel aux patrons s'il le
faut et si ça n'est pas suffisant
réclame la patronne accablante ainsi son
pauvre compagnon d'un complexe
d'infériorité
et c'est ainsi qu'on gâche une soirée
elle m'a dit quelque chose je serais
volontiers resté plus longtemps écoutez
madame betty fils mais j'ai dû la
quitter
me proposant de tirer profit pour mon
compte personnel de ces bons
enseignements et ja les avoir à les
mettre en pratique plutôt que je ne
pensais au monsieur l'agent vous m'avez
mis un pv pourquoi moi je ne l'avais pas
vu ça ne m'arrive jamais vous savez
c'est bien la première fois je serai
plus
merci monsieur l'agent russe
[Musique]
oh
monsieur l'agent maintenait grever
[Musique]
si vous saviez tout ce qu'on peut
obtenir avec un sourire
[Musique]
et
et je n'en suis qu'à ma première leçon
[Musique]